yep it was all about a more and more and
more for jennifer lopez and ben affleck
with a fairy tale wedding weekend fit
for jennifer welcome everybody to
entertainment tonight you know what we
are going to make you feel like you are
a guest et's brooke anderson is on the
ground in georgia with all the i do
details
thanks kevin and nichelle yeah everybody
here in savannah is still buzzing over
benefits i do's the guests basically
took over the entire town for the
three-day event and how do we know that
it was a super fun exhausting weekend i
mean check out ben's face on sunday
night when it was all over waiting for
tonight
fireworks an all-white dress code and
jlo's 20-foot veil the three-day wedding
event did not disappoint and a source
tells e.t ben and jen remained cool calm
and collected through it all
jlo was stunning in a white ralph lauren
gown topping off the gorgeous look with
a dramatic sheer
length veil then matched his bride
wearing a white tuxedo jacket black
trousers and a black bow tie after the
ceremony the newlyweds posed for photos
and videos all over the 87 acre property
their five kids also joined in
coordinating in all white and will the
kids
have a hand in what
of course can't have can't have it
without the kids i was outside ben's
very private estate as the excitement
started to unfold
here's a timeline of the wedding events
matt damon and his family were spotted
arriving by private plane on friday
afternoon on saturday we spotted luxury
auto company all drain motorsports
getting here around 2 45 with a car
under wraps 315 two catering trucks
entered the property and at four o'clock
old savannah tours entered with some
trolley buses 20 minutes later officiant
jay shetty left the perry lane hotel in
savannah and of course security has been
working around the clock
guests at the perry lane hotel were
greeted with this goody bag with a jp
inscription on it on sunday the couple
capped off the weekend with a brunch and
barbecue
who wasn't there for the big ideas well
all the exes of course jen garner was
spotted out at a sam's club in her home
state of west virginia with her
boyfriend john miller j-lo's ex-husband
of seven years marc anthony was in miami
saluting workers at a marina there and
her most recent ex a-rod was also in
miami where he hit the gym
[Music]
the weekend wedding comes just over a
month after benifer tied the knot in
vegas and more than 21 years after jen
told us this i love outdoor weddings i
would you know when i got married the
first time
because i'm hoping there will be a
second time one day um will you get
married a second time i think so yeah
absolutely yeah i believe in marriage
even though mines didn't work out the
first time not the point um but the
outdoor weddings are great yeah they are
back in savannah ben's longtime friend
movie producer ice cream shop owner
stratton leopold made this prediction to
et of course they're together again
forever they complement each other so
well they're both family oriented which
is crucial i think to any relationship
and they have that down stratton a
savannah native produced two films
co-starring ben 2002's the sum of all
fears and 2003's paycheck i mean what's
in our future
you know
i don't know met ben in 99 in montreal
work ethic was great he also met
jennifer around that time during an
audition we auditioned jennifer for the
general's daughter we didn't cast her
that's when i first met her
and then of course when i did the second
picture with ben in vancouver we did
paycheck and she was there with us on
set all these years later stratton is
still getting the scoop this time as the
owner of his 103 year old family
business leopold's ice cream ben would
come here still does ben loves our
butter pecan we usually sit on that on a
bench up front there and just just talk
they come in here with the kids the
scrum of publicity it
typically doesn't happen here